- f - yagh 'with car tester run a
lipstick says Jaguars f-type is such a
beautiful sports car that it's hard to
improve on it but it's received a minor
facelift now it has full LED headlights
and air scoops on the front bumper to
cool the brakes this is a special
edition the 400 Sport actor and sonamoo
de anza definite spot most special
editions are limited by number but not
with the 400 Sport the limitation is it
will be built for just one year the 400
sport comes only with an automatic
transmission the price for the coupe a
begins at just under 100,000 euros in
Germany the convertible which we'll be
test driving costs at least seven
thousand more
Fiona it's called the 400 sport because
it has 400 horsepower that translates as
15 kilowatts more than the normal f-type
but it has the same torque still you can
feel and hear the extra power when you
accelerate this model roars and moons
and thanks to the torque vectoring
system and all-wheel drive the f-type
can take curves fast
well Dominique or mountaintop vectoring
system :
I love antique seats the f-type box and
polish Nick over
Ronnie says it's also possible to take a
leisurely drive in the 400 switching off
the dynamic mode closes the exhaust
valve cover and makes the suspension
markedly softer step on the gas and the
engine still furs gently for the ship
the 3 litre v6 engine has a compressor
it's 294 kilowatts bring it up to 100
kilometers an hour in 5.1 seconds and to
a top speed of 275 kilometres an hour no
question that is sports car performance
even though at 1722 kilograms the
vehicle is fairly heavy this Jaguar is a
lot of fun Jesus thoughts are coming out
of two Hispanic the cars adaptive
suspension means Ronnie can switch drive
moments that substantially improves
performance
now he's choosing dynamic mode to get
the sportiest performance
[Music]
the Jaguar f-type 400 Sport is perfect
for those who love detail and can afford
a luxury car what distinguishes the 400
Sport from the normal f-type s
dangerous-looking side skirts big brake
discs 380 millimetres in diameter
dark 20 inch wheel rims and yellow
badging not much about the interior
design is changed from the conventional
f-type when you turn on the fan
the ventilation grilles rise up from the
dashboard 10 F - yah Ronnie says the
Jaguar f-type now comes in 28 different
configurations v8 or v6 engine manual or
automatic transmission rear-wheel or
all-wheel drive coupe a or like here a
convertible variant Ronnie says it's a
thrill to drive the 400 Sport fast with
the top down but he does find one
drawback it's not much for long trips
the most the trunk will hold is to tote
bags but there are alternatives Porsches
Carrera convertible offers a rumble seat
a few pieces of luggage would fit on it